fight on easy
once we're in this in this bar and we're
having a good time something happens
there's a commotion I see my friend Ryan
get kind of rushed out of the bar so I
ran out there and my friend Ryan like
the kid immediately took off his shirt
he like threw it at me for I grabbed it
and like rubbed my face with it and
immediately like threw a punch at this
kid and all of the sudden I'm like on
ecstasy and I am the best boxer I've
ever been feel every move in your head
no in real life in like every fiber of
my body kind of locked in in a way dude
I was reading his moves I mean granted
he was probably shitfaced but I'm just
like I'm Neo in The Matrix moving so
fast it's slow dude drugs are so great
in that way that they make you get out
of your own way and you literally like
harness all of your potential that's the
double edge that's the double play that
at a middle school yeah disclaimer no
which is why I'm saying not even
close